why do you like twist endings huh I uh I
guess I love them as a kid growing up I
loved trying to uh you know see the
twist coming trying to solve it
um I you know I rarely could as a kid
and I just love the idea of of your your
expectations and your experience kind of
being turned on its head and with
something else all along I love that and
I've
um on Ghost Whisperer we started
developing this idea of twists with with
you know every episode and then twist
upon twists and all kinds of things and
so I really got uh very comfortable with
it in that and loved it and now in these
short films
um I'm doing it all the time I just uh
you know almost all of them have had at
least one twist I usually try to get
three twists in to really confuse the
audience of it they don't see it coming
and the short film it's particularly
difficult because you have so little
time to lay the pipe for for a Twist and
so the audience and you know if they
know there's going to be a Twist they
know they're watching this film because
it can't possibly just be this there's
got to be something else going on with
this character
um so you have to it's a delicate
balance of having to try to redirect the
audience
and sort of have a red hairy twist that
they think it's going to be and then the
actual twist which they can never see
coming and every movie I do it becomes
harder and harder to come up with that
Twist of you know well we never saw that
coming but it's fun it's a great
challenge to do it why would you say
it's become harder is that because so
much has been done
so much has been done and you know
there's a thing of trying to top
yourself uh and again it's the short
film sort of format
and um uh and sometimes I work I just
start with the ending if I'm trying to
develop a Twist I start with the ending
and then I go backwards
um how how many convolutions can I take
away from this ending that that makes it
a surprise it makes it a Twist or yeah
and then by doing it backwards
something that I can write a script in a
linear way beginning to end with one
final twist
but then I'll go backwards and think
about where else can I put another twist
where is there oh look in scene three I
could plant this seed that No One's
Gonna really notice but then it's going
to pay off in this scene and then when
the twist happens everyone will be an
aha moment of oh that's why those things
were there uh so it's just it's a it's a
mechanical thing in a way it's like a
Craftsman kind of thing to to do a good
twist
and so now I've just I kind of love them
and every time I write a short film I
become terrified I'm not gonna be able
to find a good twist or enough of them
what is the Hollywood ending and what's
wrong with the Hollywood ending
I don't know what that means today you
know I mean I think at a certain point
in film history it referred to the idea
of everyone is happy everything's tied
up in a bow and you know your leave the
theater completely satisfied and
everything's good and yeah there's
certainly nothing wrong with that and
that's certainly what a lot of people go
to the movies for uh they don't you know
they don't want to have enough
depression and unhappiness in their
lives they don't need to see it on
screen but um for an artist that's
normally just an unsatisfying way to
work and uh you're for most writers and
directors and actors you
um you know you you just want to do work
that reflects life a little more it
doesn't have to be not uplifting but uh
you know realistic I just wanted to be a
little more realistic and I think that
the idea of a Hollywood ending it's not
really uh prevalent that much anymore I
think because of the streaming you know
influx of streaming services and digital
everything I think audiences are growing
more sophisticated
and are more willing to accept a
convoluted ending or you know a more
complex ending and uh I mean I haven't
gotten a note like that in years about
you know about an ending to make it more
palatable or more Hollywood
how do you pull off a twist ending well
it's it's really like a magician's trick
it's about misdirection
it's about telling the audience to look
over here when what I'm really doing is
over here
and it's really tricky because you were
just talking about how sophisticated
audiences are today so you know they see
it coming right away so you really got
to be careful and what I try to do with
like a you know a triple twist kind of a
thing is I set something up
that the audience right away feels like
oh that's what this is what it's going
to be it's going to be I know it I can
tell right away
and you you play that along and then at
the same time I try to introduce what I
would call the red herring twist
which is a little thing that you you you
weave into a scene that you do in such a
way that the audience is going to notice
it
and they're going to think that they
just caught you ah this is why this
guy's there because in the end it's
going to be that and you play that and
if you've seen you you play those
expectations and you try to disguise it
uh like I'm being clever now and I'm
gonna try to pull this over on you but
you're too smart for me
and in the meantime there's a third
thing that just comes out of the blue
that they never saw coming it's been
there the whole time because you can't
just do a these ex machina you just you
can't just you've got to have it woven
in but it's something that they never
really thought about as as something's
going to pay off
so you know this sounds very esoteric
it's it becomes more obvious in the
actual execution of it but that's my
that's the way I do it you know and like
oftentimes I'll my first pass on the
script I'll do the obvious
Choice and then the the red herring
Choice and then I gotta really struggle
to figure okay how is it even different
even another Twist on this twist that we
plant in the beginning that no one
realizes we've been tracking this whole
time
you know so it's it's fun it's great fun
to pull it off and it's what's wonderful
about it and I love some about my short
films is to sit in an audience you know
in a theater uh at a film festival and
you have people react to those twists
it's fantastic and it's one of the
things I love about short films by the
way
um because of my TV work I didn't I was
a connected to the audience
um you know everyone's watching on TV in
their home and I don't know but uh on
the film festival circuit uh where I'm a
regular with these short films it's
phenomenal and people seem to love short
films these these screenings are packed
and we get these big theaters and it's
it's about as good experience as you can
have making a movie watching your story
unfold even if it's just 10 minutes uh
with an audience that you know that gets
it is there a director or writer
director that you remember from the
beginning watching movies back in in
Brooklyn that was the master of the
twist ending
well you know I mean I guess Hitchcock
of course comes to mind you know
immediately
um
but uh I I think I became more enamored
as a kid of the twist ending in
literature in things I would read
and you know you're so much uh you have
so much more opportunity to do twists in
fiction because the your readers can't
see anything
so you could be describing a character
or a location uh in a way that can
disguise the fact that it's really this
or this person is really that person the
unreliable narrator but you don't have
that luxury uh with a movie because
they're gonna they're seeing everything
you're doing
um so it's you're that much more
challenging but the answer to the
question is as a kid I remember
um you know reading detective fiction
and and that kind of stuff and really
being drawn in by a good twist that I
didn't see coming
should the end of a story always tie
back to the beginning
uh I don't know if if it always yeah
like a rule um uh I think is great if it
does it's a great thing visually to do
and uh I think it gives the audience
more of a feeling that they've done this
complete Journey
um
you know I did it not to a granddose
myself you know but uh I I did a movie
Once about the relationship between
Jerry Lewis and Dean Martin
and I began the movie in Dean Martin's
dressing room
on a close-up of a glass of scotch with
ice cubes in it
and I held that for a long time in the
background you could hear a nightclub
because some muffled comic and people
laughing and hooting and and that hand
came into the frame and took the drink
and we revealed Dean Martin
and at the end of the movie when they
break up
uh it also happens in this time in
Jerry's dressing room
and they're saying goodbye they just
said they have farewell performance of
the Copacabana we've gone through it's
like 10 years of their lives
and when Dean says goodbye and they just
have the very awkward kind of parting
full of pain talk about subtext you know
they're dying inside each one of them
but neither one can talk about it they
can just do these perfunctory good show
yeah best one okay good take care yeah
meantime it's like oh don't leave me
um so we did the scene and then
afterwards I leave with Jerry just
looking in the mirror when Dean's walked
away and I pan down and I I find a glass
of scotch just mirror the first shot you
know totally and so I mean that's just
an example again not that like you know
but it was I'm such a genius but those
are really great visual ways to tie
things in and I had to fight with the
network about keeping that you know cut
on his face just cut out on his face no
no there's a reason uh but anytime you
can tie in the beginning to the end or
any other part of the movie you know
callbacks are always yeah they'll you
know the joke in movies you know you can
never pull a gun on screen without
having that gun play somehow in the
movie you can't show it you can and I
feel like that's true about everything
in the movie you can't introduce
anything in a film that doesn't somehow
call back later and even if it's a
character
um you know everything in the movie has
to be there for a reason and I think it
teaches you a great discipline in
writing if you try to apply that
everything you write okay I'm going to
introduce this prop this this person is
this event and it can't be just there
for the sake of being there it's got to
be there to serve the story and so how
do we call it back later on
and callbacks were different than
bookending
I suppose so I mean I think they can be
the same but they could also be
different in that you know a callback uh
it just could be just even just a fun
thing where we we see uh a joke
introduced at the beginning of a film
someone always loses their glove and
then uh you know a third of the way
through the film that that comes up
again uh that lose the glove
um and again it's an example of like
never like something go to waste don't
don't introduce someone who loses the
glove and then not somehow bring them
back later not pay that off in some way
uh so you know I think if you have to be
strict strict about it you know bookends
obviously being in the end of a film and
callbacks can just happen anywhere in
the body of a movie but also I don't
want to feel like there's rules like
that they really aren't it's just about
what what you feel works for your story